welcome guys
um I'm gonna be talking to you today
about modern data analytics in the cloud
and I'm going to make a case for fraud
detection so hi my name is Mara Ahmed
I'm a data analytics consultant I'm an
AWS solution architect and beta
specialist
and today I'm going to be talking about
a few things first one is the analytics
Evolution from monolithic to Modern
architectures we're going to do some
deep dive on the modern data
architectures on AWS I'm going to make a
case for fraud detection and then I'll
show you how fraud detection can be done
in the cloud and then we'll talk about a
deep dive in the solution that I provide
for you and lastly we're going to talk
about scaling and Improvement for the
solution
so with that let's talk about how did
the analytics evolve over time so
actually analytics and software are very
coupled together and they followed the
same Evolution so we started from
monolithic architectures so I'm making
the case for an e-commerce website that
we all know so here if you look on the
left you'll see that this is one Amazon
page that has over eight Services uh
stacked on top of each other so that
would translate into single database
layer in that case it was an oracle DB
that has some application for layer
written in C and then you would have the
web layer on top of it so you would have
multiple Services all in one monolithic
application and if you ever want to
scale it you'd have to scale it
vertically not horizontally so the
application logic is really stacked and
it's super hard to develop because you'd
have to go over 2000 lines of code to
actually make one small change for the
batch analytics it's actually very
limited because you would have to do
very expensive joins and you would need
to understand the schemas of of one
database that at companies like all the
different Services one database that
serves all that's very difficult to
manage if there's schema changes and you
would also have to communicate that with
your other analysts lastly the data is
exposed directly from the database so
this could actually post some access and
latency issues
so from there we move to the
microservices architecture where we
actually break down the services into
independent services that are decoupled
and they can scale themselves
horizontally the application logic is
isolated so the data is accessed by an
API the use case there is use case uh
driven batch analytics and what that
means is that if your bi analysts want
to look at a specific service they would
just have to do or run the queries for
that one database that is responsible
for the service instead of having to
access D1 database
there's also specialized data storage so
depending on the use case and the data
access patterns you can develop your own
uh data store that could be a SQL or
nosql database and then there is a push
model for the data into specialized uh
stories what what that means is like if
you have your application data uh that's
accessed from an API you would take the
data and you would push it into an S3
bucket so that's what a push model is
and lastly it's the modern data
architecture that we're at right now and
the way this works is that you have one
service that can be talking to multiple
purpose-driven or purpose-built data
stores so this allows you to have
real-time processing real-time reporting
fault tolerant data processes why I say
fault aren't is because once the data
lands in S3 or like your data Lake in
general that means the data can be
stored there like for a long time it's a
durable scalable and cost effective
storage so if any of your Downstream
processes fail at least you have the
data that's untouched you can scale the
solution and uh it allows you to have
high available applications as well so
if one of your clusters go down you can
spin up another cluster to take over the
uh the workload and this also allows you
to develop serverless compute so you
have you don't have to worry about
spinning up Pub servers in the cloud
lastly there is the pub sub data model
that has been developed where you can
have the data being pushed by one
publisher and you'll have multiple
subscribers using this data
foreign
so to break it down a little bit further
the modern data architecture has some
key features it starts really by the
data Lake which is a scalable and cost
effective raw data store that allows
managed access and governance practices
data movement is very flexible to
support multiple data logic so you'd
have data moving from inside out or
outside into your applications you would
have the data moving in around the
perimeter so it's like moving between
applications and different data stores
so this really requires a lot of
flexibility with the schema but also
with the data movement there is the data
we're housing that leverages massive
massively parallel processing engines to
build your olap processes there's the
data discovery that allows you to when
discover the schema of your data but
also have a unified metadata store that
can be accessed by multiple applications
at the same time
you also have the purpose-built data
source that allows you to have different
data stores depending on the access
patterns and data consumption purposes
so for example for your analyst you
would because they're very familiar with
a SQL type of environment so it have
your relational databases but for
application development to do something
like a nosql database and lastly
Predictive Analytics so this is really
the capabilities that can support
real-time big data processing and also
analytics using custom ml models or open
source Technologies like Hadoop
so as it looks on AWS it's really a
process that starts by Central data lake
so you would get the data and you would
put it into your central data lake with
manage access and governance for the raw
data so we call this the row uh the row
data Zone and then you would store the
data into a SQL or an O SQL database
depending on your use case for that
Amazon offers two uh main products for
the SQL you'd have RDS and Aurora and
for the nosql you'd have dynamodb as the
store this is not an exhaustive list
there is much more than that but these
are the more popular Solutions so after
you push your data into the purpose of
purpose-built stores you would validate
the data using SQL and put it into a new
created bucket so you could use Athena
for that and Athena is really a SQL
engine that's built in
um in Presto and this allows you to
access the data in F3 right away so you
do like uh queries like aggregation
queries really fast without having to
move the data at all finally you would
push the data into your warehouse for
analytics purposes and then you would
have the bi tools that are like
Downstream processes for your business
analysts to view the data directly so
you can use Athena from that or you can
actually access it directly from
redshift finally if you have a use case
like searching products machine learning
use cases or streaming uh products you'd
actually use sagemaker or EMR for that
so today I really wanted to make a case
for fraud detection and there's a really
good reason for that by just looking at
the numbers you see that it's like the
cost of fraudulent transactions in 2023
is projected to be 41 billion dollars
that's US Dollars and it's costing a lot
of e-commerce businesses a lot of money
and um it actually is representing 22 of
the retail sales which is actually
growing from uh from 19 pre-covered
and you have on average everyday Global
e-commerce businesses deal with uh
approximately a thousand uh transactions
frauds and transactions or 200 000
transactions per month so there's really
a case for it and this was really fueled
by covet acceleration because of all the
contactless payment and the reason like
all the The Source shutting down so the
brick and mortars uh shutting down
everyone had to move to the e-commerce
business so businesses were growing at
rather rapidly unbelievable rates you
had 14 1400 companies joining stripe
every day in 2021 which is incredible
the rise of contactless payment so with
that fraudulent transactions increased
by 14 from their pre-coveted levels and
you have more than one in two e-commerce
versions reporting every day that
they're experiencing some type of fraud
um this is also a personal reason for me
but that's why I was Consulting with my
clients on this um on this project
because at the time before covet even
there was a really uh Rising popularity
for the Drop Shipping model and for
people who do not uh know what droplet
shipping model is is basically you would
set up your store and Shopify and you
would connect with a supplier that space
overseas that would offer you wholesale
prices and then you would sell your uh
your product at retail prices so you
would make the difference it's actually
a legitimate model that can make you a
lot of money but it has its own
disadvantages because if your seller is
not verified that would be so hard
um that'd be so hard for you to actually
one verify it but also detect any
fraudulent transactions that could
happen on the seller side or the
consumer side so actually in 2020 uh in
2020 20 of the stores on Shopify were
labeled as fraudulent 39 of which were
selling counterfeit products or deemed
fishy merchants and 12 of the stores in
2021 were Drop Shipping at least one
product so that's a lot of foliant for
potential uh fraudulent activities
online
so I kind of wanted to go over just uh
some types of fraud these are not
exhaustive lists but these are the more
popular ones and after each one are like
below each um fraudulent activity or
fraudulent type what I did is I added a
detection score and this really
represents my personal belief of how
easy it is to detect this type of fraud
but also from the research that I had
done for my client
um so we'll start by the chargeback
fraud and this is really like when a
customer orders something and uses a
credit card and then after they get the
product they would contact their credit
card and say I want to avoid this
purchase and deem it as chargeback so I
might myself as a store owner or the
immersion I would have to pay you back
uh and that's how I gave a score of nine
because it's really hard to detect uh
whether this is a legitimate uh this is
legitimate transaction or not because it
could be and you would never know that
uh the customer would actually uh charge
it back to you the second type is a
refund fraud where the fraudster would
actually purchase the product and then
they would offer or like they would
submit a refund request and that I give
a detection score of 10 because it's so
hard to one distinguish between the
legitimate transactions so people who
actually want to return the product but
also the fraudulent transactions where
like people just buy the product and
they use another card to do the the
refund and this is really one of the uh
harder to not just harder to detect but
also like it's getting very creative to
these types of activities
um so it's also like evolving over time
uh on the other side you have the
account takeover fraud which is a little
bit easier to detect like people with
like steel per like uh steal passwords
or security codes online and then they
would use these to actually access the
customers accounts and then virtually
they could do everything they want or
buy as many products as they want
um the last one is card testing which
actually took a similar score
um so car testing is one of like a
fraudster would buy multiple
um credit cards whether they steal it or
you get it from somewhere else and then
they would keep trying every card to see
which is valid and these are easier to
detect because you can have like capture
like the capture option at checkout you
can have like a card not present
verification so you'd have to be
um directed to the bank to confirm that
this card is actually active so this is
actually easier to detect but also
easier to prevent
so I wanted to introduce to you how
fraud was actually being done in the old
days and then from there we can develop
the more modern solution that I provide
for you today so the like the front at
the time and like the old good old days
it was actually a rule-based type of
pipeline so what happens is that you
would have like the customer making an
order and then the order will be
submitted to some uh like to your sum
application logic in the back end and
the back end would use a rule-based
engine so for example it'd be something
like if the browser IP does not match
the uh billing country for example so
where they made the order and if the
customer is coordinating they're 70 and
the transaction amount is more than a
thousand dollars then you would block
the transaction once the transaction is
left it would actually get flagged to
your front team so your front analyst
and they would do the manual review
this solution is actually great for two
reasons one is that the logic is so
human readable so you can understand how
the decision is being made and the fraud
team can use their domain expertise um
to actually build these rules but it
also has it its disadvantages three of
them being that new customers will have
no scores so for new people for new
customers that just uh make purchases on
your store you'd have to do some sort of
extrapolation to the customers that you
have existing in your data store so for
example you do like uh some type of
clustering techniques but that also
requires technical expertise
and you also have the rule-based logic
that can get very complicated so yes
it's easy with three rules but then if
you have 20 25 or even 100 rules you can
actually uh lose the decision process or
know why is the decision being made so
it could get very complicated lastly the
nature of this analytical pipeline is
batch so it's actually not going to be
easy to catch the fraud transaction
especially like the chargeback and the
refund on time
so now I want to talk to you about like
how is it done in the cloud and there's
there's like three like three to four
benefits of uh doing the analytics and
the cloud the product detection
analytics in the cloud but it also
doesn't come at a cheap Class it has its
own disadvantages so in terms of good uh
decision in terms of like good
advantages or um good points for it is
that have real-time detection
um so you can actually capture
everything that's happening right away
instead of having to bear the cost of
yourself as a merchant you can have
trained model that will be exposed to an
API so that would be easy to deploy and
you could just call the API endpoint
directly
um you would have real-time reporting on
your transactions or accounts you would
know the activities in real time but it
would also have continuous model update
and Improvement
this is perfect but it comes at some
certain costs so for example without
enough data your performance can be
compromised especially during the first
30 to 60 days of deployment because it
takes time to mature the transactions
especially the frontal transactions
secondly technical expertise is required
and without having like machine learning
uh domain knowledge is going to be
really hard to develop uh the model to
actually do the training and the
detection accurate like you need high
quality accurate data labeling uh and
this would require a lot of time but
also a lot of technical expertise lastly
the model driven insights that you get
from the training can actually have
negative impact on customer satisfaction
and this for example if you have like
one customer that's being blocked
multiple times because of the model is
labeling them as high risk you would
actually have that customer probably
like leaving after a few a few of those
uh like blocking activities
so as it looks on AWS there's three ways
to do the fraud detection this is not an
exhaustive list but these are the more
popular uh Solutions so first off you
have sagemaker uh which is just another
way of deploying Python and R and in the
cloud
um and using your own domain expertise
you have EMR which you can use to
leverage like open source Technologies
like ml lib and Hadoop and you have the
fraud detector which is the AWS managed
service
so in terms of like the how everything
compares to each other for the sagemaker
and EMR you would need a deployment
endpoint but for the fraud it actually
for the fraud detector it comes with a
deployment itself so you don't have to
worry about like deploying that endpoint
after you train the model it actually
does that for you in terms of Dev time
the two the first two options so
sagemaker and EMR could take days two
weeks depending on your expertise but
also with EMR it depends on your Hadoop
expertise for the fraud detector it
could take hours to days depending on
how much the training process and
building the data takes
lastly for orchestration for sagemaker
and EMR you would need to build a
pipeline for development so you can
actually develop the entire machine
learning pipeline but for the fraud
detector it's already included in the
service so as you can see there's a lot
of good benefits to using the fraud
detector right away and actually this is
using Amazon's 20 years of expertise in
e-commerce and they're using that engine
to um to actually do the front detection
in Eco in in amazon.com
so how does it work you actually first
start by choosing a model and there's
two models currently supported and the
fraud detector there's the transaction
front insights model there's the account
front insights model so that's the first
part and then you would have to Define
operating ranges for your valuation what
that means is uh you would have to
choose an acceptable false positive rate
so the transactions that will be labeled
as fraudulent when they're actually not
versus a fraud capture rate which is
your true positive rate and um if you
already like have done any machine
learning projects before you know that
there is like the the ROC uh curve so
there is usually like
um a trade-off between the false
positive rate and the true positive rate
so you would want to see what's
acceptable for your business and then
you would get the data so uh there is
actually minimum transactions required
for both models so you would need 10 000
at least 10 000 records 400 of which are
labeled as fraudulent then you would
train the model so locate the S3 bucket
where the training data is uploaded and
then start the automl pipeline to train
them model lastly you would use uh you
would use your domain expertise so the
rules that you built from your
rule-based engine to do some business
logic and add the decision rules to
categorize your transactions and this is
the uh creating the detector part and
you can actually then use the detector
that's already deployed as an endpoint
you would actually use the get get event
predictions API to test it with other
services
so the next part we want to talk about
is really getting the data what if you
have less than 10 000 transactions and
you're just a newly started store you'd
actually have to use synthetic sampling
techniques like smolten python to over
sample your fraudulent transactions to
at least 40 percent uh and there's like
multiple uh ways that you can do this
and then something also to consider when
you're getting the training data is
label maturity so usually it takes 30 to
45 days to start to detect the
fraudulent transactions correctly so
ideally your training data has to be
four to six weeks old and you cannot
have data that's from 2018 to predict uh
Frontline transactions in 2022 or 2023.
the reason for that is fraud activities
develop quite a lot and there is like
usually changing Trends so you'd want
the data to be old but not too old
and then you would develop a data
profile so also known as your Eda so
your exploratory data analysis to see
what are missing values how can you
impute how can you replace and lastly
build your feature set so that like with
that you'll have the training data to
actually train the detector
so I decided to give you an idea of what
feature set is
um is responsible it's like your
responsibility as a user but also what
is the responsibility of AWS to kind of
give you an idea of what you can do with
a detector so in terms of independent
features the main ones that you have to
provide as a user would be the customer
first name last name address email
shipping address event timestamp the
label the entity and the event ID and
these are the last four fields that
actually required Fields but AWS doesn't
provide anything for you in terms of
independent features however for data
aggregations usually what you do is that
you would have like a customer like a
column that has all the customers
previous orders and how many orders they
have done their values but for that like
for the fraud detector case you don't
have to do that because the fraud
detector in of itself is a data
aggregation engine so it would actually
build these uh fields for you right away
you don't have to do it yourself so this
also cuts a lot of the development time
and the the querying part
so for validation on the user's end you
do not have to do but it's like it's
recommended that you do because the
detector itself does all the validation
so it does it does like imputation
replacement for missing values it does
like uh checks for the IP addresses
formats the email addresses formats
there is like more than 100 validation
intervals in the detector for
partitioning a resampling because like
in the typical machine learning pipeline
what you would do is that you would
split your data into train test
validation you do not have to do this
because the fraud detector does it uh
automatically for you so for feature
enrichment and Engineering usually you
would spend quite a lot of time to see
what features make sense for you but for
the fraud detector this actually comes
uh pre-built and into the engine so I do
like IP address enrichment with parse
text Fields capture the categorical
variables and turn them into numerical
and so on it also has feature importance
of hyper parameter tuning
um potential so it actually has the
features built into the engine and you
don't have to do any of these yourself
so the modern solution that I provide
for you today is actually a solution
that allows you to run serverless
compute that's event driven and allows
you to do real-time fraud capture it has
its Purpose Driven storage that allows
you to optimize your storage in terms of
cost scalability but also performance
and it's a scalable solution that can
scale up to uh stores that handle 50 to
60 000 transactions per month
so for breaking down the architecture I
wanted to start by like the first part
which uh which really starts from a web
hooks integration between Shopify and
eventbridge so eventbridge is the event
handler for AWS and once the order is
made it will be routed into two uh into
two destinations the first is the sqsq
to which an SNS topic will be subscribed
so you will get a notification that an
order has been placed and then the
serverless Lambda function that will
push the orders to dynamodb which is an
optimal store for this type of
transactions it's very it can handle
high velocity of orders and then another
Lambda function will push it to uh S3
for both storage
the second part of the architecture is
the the same Lambda function will
actually process the orders and do some
enrichment on the features if you have
domain expertise and what features would
actually go besides what's offered by
the front detector you would do the
enrichment yourself and then prepare
them for a prediction once you push that
into its own curated bucket you would
have the Lambda function called the
endpoint using the get event prediction
API and then the predictions would be
put into an S3 bucket for future
training so you can continuously improve
your model which is also going to be
consumed by Downstream bi processes like
Tableau or quickside
so if the transaction is labeled as
fraud what will happen is that
um obviously this depends on the
decision rules that you set during the
training and the fraud create like fraud
detector creation step once it's labeled
this fraud it will actually be routed to
sqs to which your fraud analyst will be
subscribed so you will know that like
they will know that there's a
transaction that requires manual review
and if it's not labeled fraudulent what
will happen is that it will
automatically pass to the Fulfillment
service so all of this is event driven
you don't have to do any of the
intervention yourself
lastly we also built the analytics part
so you have an S3 bucket that will be
consumed by the bi analyst for reporting
you would have a redshift a query that
would actually sorry you'd have a
redshift copy statement that would be
pushing the data from s3h redshift for
analytics and you'd have a query that's
scheduled to run to update the quickside
dashboards and all of this can be
orchestrated by step functions or data
pipeline
so with this solution really offers is a
simple way to build the entire workflow
and tend it really cuts the development
time significantly so for me it took
five days to get the entire solution up
and running for testing but it also
could take a lot more than that because
of how hard it is actually uh to get the
data the training data and actually
build it if you don't have enough
transactions the code part is limited to
only the Lambda function development so
depending on the language of choice you
want the architecture can also be
applied to other use cases such as
social media monitoring so you take the
same detection logic but also apply it
to monitoring your social media accounts
in real time however no solution is
always perfect it has its own
disadvantages advantages so the first
one is that the Lambda timeouts after 15
minutes so if it if you have like
multiple orders and you do a lot of uh
processing it would actually time out
and
um that would really
um like remove the real-time aspect of
the architecture the if the web hooks
integration fails for any reason your
data is going to be lost forever and
then lastly building the training data
requires a lot of time and expertise but
this model has been tested on e-commerce
websites that handle 40 000 transactions
per month so it is actually scalable the
AUC will achieved the AUC that was
achieved on 70 000 transactions was 84
which is pretty good as a start and the
reduction in fraud rate in the first 30
days of deployment was three percent
well in terms of scaling start to
interrupt you have five minutes left yes
thank you
so scaling and improving the solution
for like three things that came to mind
to improve the solution the first one is
that you would have to handle some uh of
the API throttling so the predictions
are limited to 200 predictions per
second so you'd have to like Implement
your reply retry Logic for that you can
also use ECS or ec2 to scale the uh to
scale like your workload instead of
using Lambda functions and you can use
some sort of infrastructure as a code so
for example terraform or cloud formation
due to the automatic scaling of the
entire architecture
so with that I'm actually done
um thank you so much for listening and
if you guys have any questions feel free
to follow me on LinkedIn or connect with
me on LinkedIn or follow me on Twitter
and um I have a podcast starting soon so
stay tuned for that as well
but thank you if you have any questions
please answer like please ask right away